evening everyone
tonight we're lucky enough to have with
us Tom Welles and I hope we all can
welcome him to Boulder we're all glad to
have him here thank everyone here for
coming out and supporting your local
bookstore and that's uh you know Barnes
Noble or Borders or anything like that
and Tom is fairly accomplished he has a
PhD in sociology from Berkeley and
tonight we're gonna be dealing with his
book wild man the life and times of
Daniel Ellsberg which deals specifically
with the Pentagon's Papers importance
and let's start here the Pentagon Papers
importance notwithstanding when one
think the life of man whose fame rests
on a single dissonant Act could sustain
a 700 page biography but Tom Welles wild
man succeeds terrifically a first-rate
historian of the anti-war movement
Welles understands Vietnam Vietnam hold
on America like such interpreters of the
conflict of Milan Tim O'Brien Stanley
Kubrick well sides politically with the
anti-war cause but seldom lets his
sympathies harden his simplicity's I'm
sorry into simplicity's rather in this
extensively researched and engaging ly
written account
Ellsberg comes across as all at once
a brilliant military analysts are
devoted often fanatical convert to the
peace effort a victim of Nick Nick
Nixon's skullduggery ended obnoxious and
sometimes honest you go maniac dishonest
on the whole however Wells is a fair and
perceptive chronicler of the time and is
sometimes inspirational sometimes
maddening almost always fascinating
figure more important he is an
exceptional historian of the
inspirational maddening and fascinating
political drama of which Daniel Ellsberg
was a small but significant part Tom
Welles
so about the title Wildman
some people may wonder how I came up
with that title some people may even
think it's somewhat sensationalistic the
origins the origins of that title are
basically as follows I interviewed two
people who described Daniel Ellsberg as
a wild man and then I saw in another
book where someone else was quoted as
describing Daniel Ellsberg as a wild man
so the tight so that the phrase had a
certain ring to me and then of course my
publisher loved it when the marketing
departments thought they thought that
was quite a nice title and and it's
actually a very apt description of
Daniel Ellsberg it speaks to basically
his disorganized quality his
undisciplined side his adventuresome
spirit his risk-taking and also his at
times in his life his somewhat frenetic
out-of-control States so that's the
origins of the title now what I thought
I'd do tonight mainly is talk about the
background of the book and a little bit
about why I chose to write about Daniel
Ellsberg I'm not going to quote
extensively from the book I'm not a poet
and I'm not I'm little worried about how
it's going to come off in terms of my
enunciation and whether I give it the
right you know thrust and such I'll
quote some excerpts from it but mainly
I'm going to talk about it
in terms of the background of the book I
initially sent a letter to Daniel
Ellsberg back in July of 1994 and the
first sentence of a letter which was
also the first paragraph of the letter
said I'm writing to let you know that I
am writing a biography of you that was
the whole first paragraph and then in
the letter I also said that though my
book will consider you as an individual
as well as a political figure I'm more
interested in history and
Hixton personality now probably now he
feels somewhat betrayed by that if not
or if not feels that I was dishonest
about it because I in fact probe his
personality and his character quite a
lot in the book and the fact of the
matter is that was a very honest
statement of my sentiments at the time
but what happened was I started reading
books on the the art and craft of
biography and one of the commonalities
commonalities of these books is that the
the litmus test of a good biography is
the extent to which you can bring the
subjects personality and character alive
on the page so after reading about
reading these books on biography I
concluded I needed in fact I needed to
focus a lot on Daniel Ellsberg's
personality and character but any event
that was a letter there's more of a
letter and I asked him if we could get
together to talk about the book I'd
actually already broached the topic of a
biography with him several years earlier
over the phone because I'd interviewed
him for a previous book I wrote the war
within America's battle over Vietnam and
I was talking to my something of dealing
with that book and or maybe I called him
specifically about the biography and I
said you know I'm thinking about writing
a biography of you would you be
interested and he said no no I'm I want
to write a memoir so no I wouldn't be
interested so this time I decided just
to tell him I was going to write the
book instead of killing him out about it
and he later told me so anyway we got
together he called about three weeks
after I sent him this letter and we got
together and he told me later that this
letter started off on the wrong foot
started us off on the wrong foot him he
didn't like the fact that I simply told
him I was going to write the book
without asking him he said this is in
the preface he said we got off we got
off on not a good foot he felt quite
closed in he felt quote closed in on he
said it was as if I was telling him
quote I'm moving into your house I'm
taking over your life somehow he had a
strong emotional reaction he told me and
felt harried and depressed
seriously depressed she didn't even like
to think about this book it was quote
driving me nuts he said but it was not
clear he told me why he was reacting so
strongly I think I know I think I know I
was reacting so strongly that I could be
wrong I think he was mainly concerned
with what other people were going to say
about him in the book as I think I would
be if somebody ever no one will ever
write a biography of me but if someone
wrote one of me I think that would be my
first reaction what are people going to
say about me and is that going to be and
how's that going to hurt me certain
people that I might be very hurt by you
know their descriptions of me but in any
event he called me three weeks after
receiving this letter around three weeks
and we got together and we did a series
of interviews very long interviews I got
together with them eight times for this
book we're talking multi hour sessions
one of those times was actually a very
long phone interview three-hour phone
interview I also spoken with him twice I
interviewed him twice for my previous
book so we talked quite a bit but he was
always very wary about the whole process
one reason he was whereas he felt he'd
been he'd been burned badly in the past
by journalists in fact he felt he'd been
burned badly it's my perception that he
felt he'd burned badly by most
journalists would interviewed him he
also he wanted to write a memoir and he
thought that my book might be
competition to his memoir and even felt
me out about the possibility about
working with him on a memoir he asked me
whether I'd be interested in working
with mono memoir he liked my previous
book a lot and he said he couldn't think
of a better person to write a biography
of him if I was to do this book you know
if a biography was going to be written
so you know I was in good standing with
him initially even though he was aware
because he liked me a previous book and
one reason he liked my previous book
frankly I is because in my opinion I
took so uncritically most of the things
he told me about his life and his
motivations also another reason he was
wary is my approach to him
during the course of the interviews I
relate a lot of comments to him from
people I interviewed him their comments
and recollections about him I said
here's what so-and-so said and often
contradicted what he would say when he
told me and he often didn't like the
comments I relate to him from my other
sources and he sometimes made him mad
also I didn't play up to him during the
course of the interviews and I'm not
saying that because I was trying to toot
my own horn it's just the way I did it I
didn't play up to him at all in fact I
was openly contentious with him at times
and I know that because I listened to
the tapes inside transcribed the tapes
of the interviews I wouldn't recommend
that approach if you want somebody to
keep talking to you it's not a good
approach if you're gonna write a
biography I mean it's fairly stupid
approach but that's what I did and one
of the reasons I was contentious with
him at times is that he didn't always do
what he told me he was going to do in
terms of getting back to me to a certain
time or calling somebody who said he was
going to call for me etc I thought he
was fairly loose in that respect in
terms of what he'd say and what he'd
actually do I found that irritating and
he played a bit hard to get and I guess
I kind of felt like okay now that we're
here I'm here to play and you're gonna
get it kind of a certain feeling you
know a certain I mean that's may be
overstating but there's a certain
sentiment along those lines on my part I
also one reason I became contentious at
times with him was that I thought I was
getting a lot of self-serving responses
from him including untruthful ones what
I found is that he tends to distort
things about his life quite a bit to
exaggerate to overdramatize
he tends to make himself a bigger player
in historical events than he actually
was
and he even struck me as being dishonest
at times about his life
so in short or in the end he eventually
stopped talking to me he and I I'm
Italian listen to these tapes I don't
blame him at all I mean
I would have stopped talking to me - he
he said he found the whole process what
happened was we were in why I was in
Washington interviewing some people and
I thought I didn't I hoped hope to
interview him again and I called him and
he said what we got together to talk but
this is serious
and I said that well yeah it sounds
serious and cedra and we got together we
met at the Mayflower Hotel in Washington
which was I found kind of interesting
because that's where Richard Nixon hung
out sometimes with the Mayflower Hotel
in fact there's this famous episode
where Nixon there was a Fame a big
anti-war protests after Cambodia the age
of Cambodia in 1970 and Nixon couldn't
sleep that night the night before the
demonstration in here he finally got out
of bed and in his domestic servant
Manolo Sanchez he and Nixon went out
decidedly tried to talk to some of the
protesters early morning and Nixon
didn't do a very good job of
communicating with him he couldn't seem
to relate to him very well he went to
talk about football and stuff made him
wanna talk about football funny when he
wasn't rambling around and he's out
there talking these protesters you know
this is very only then when he hasn't
slept he's got his you know the Secret
Service or following him you know his
code name was searchlight they're saying
searchlight is on the lawn searchlight
is on the on circulators asked for a car
so they have to follow him when he goes
the Lincoln Memorial they're going after
this escapade a Lincoln Memorial he
ended up with the Mayflower at the
Mayflower Hotel on hand I think it's
called the rib room something like that
and he had a breakfast there with Manolo
Sanchez but anyway because I'm a big you
know I'm studied Nixon and founded find
it very interesting I thought it was
kind of interesting when Ellsberg and I
ended up at the Mayflower Hotel - any
event so what the mayflower he told me
he found that he he found the whole
process he told me the whole he found
the whole process of being interviewed
for this book unpleasant painful and
uncomfortable
he said he'd heard enough that he quote
unquote got the picture he says you know
it's it's not as bad as it could be true
but it's not good you know what he'd
heard he told me I'm not in such
wonderful spirits this doesn't do much
and he during this last session it
didn't actually start as an interview
but we ended up doing an interview
because I brought up some stuff and we
started talking so he let me turn on the
tape
quarter again and then at one point we
had just a dispute over something he
turned off my tape recorder which is
okay because a lot of people turn off
people's tape recorder other people
turned out my tape recorder too but but
any event after after but he also said
he he didn't think I understood him so
that was another reason he said for
pulling out of the biography but after
we had this discussion he took me out
for dinner and we ate dinner and and he
said goodbye anything out on the street
and said good luck I do that now a
couple reviewers have said that I was
too hard on him and you know if that's
the case I regret it if that's the case
and in fact I'd be embarrassed by it if
I it was too hard on him but I'm
convinced that I got him right that I
captured him accurately even if it's not
the portrait that some people on the
Left might want to hear of Daniel here
of Daniel Ellsberg and I and I myself
him on the left in fact I may be to the
left of Daniel Ellsberg politically I
don't know that for a fact was we didn't
talk a lot about his current political
views but I suspect on foreign policy I
probably even less likely than he is to
support a US military intervention
overseas so I'm someone on the left and
in other words uh you know I'm critical
of him but I'm not coming from a
right-wing perspective I'm someone you
know making a left critique or what's
not a left critique but just coming from
Allah so you know the result is it's not
always a pretty picture you know of
Daniel Ellsberg but my feeling is if
you're gonna write a biographer you
might as well write up write a biography
you might as well come to play and what
I came up with is what I came up with
now so Daniel Ellsberg's stopped talking
to me you know it's funny one time I was
giving a talk and my hands started
shaking as I lifted the glass I thought
that's not shaking tonight I'm very
happy that's one reason I bought this
brought this big bottle that's heavy
that's nice
so daniel ellsberg stop talking to me
but there were plenty of other people to
talk to and there was plenty of other
material to work with
I interviewed over 200 people including
former colleagues friends acquaintances
of Daniel Ellsberg former classmates of
his at in grade school Cranbrook prep
school at Harvard colleagues at the RAND
Corporation I interviewed family members
I interviewed his daughter Mary but that
was through email because she was a
nicaragua but she answered all my
questions through email
I interviewed his one of his two sons
Robert Ellsberg I interviewed his wife
Patricia Ellsberg I invaded his ex-wife
Carol Ellsberg now Carol coming she was
Carol Cummings and she became Carol
Ellsberg and then she reverted back to
Cummings because she became so tired of
being reminded of being related to
Daniel Ellsberg which we'll get into
because of the Pentagon Papers and when
I believe I heard this from Carol
herself his ex-wife but when Daniel
heard that his ex-wife was talking to me
he wasn't very happy at all and he said
something along the lines of Oh God
you can imagine I mean how many people
want their ex wife or husband to meet
our concern now I fought a lot of
battles to get access to people those
those of you who might have written
biography before you can understand how
that can take place
it was incredible as a matter of fact it
was amazing I would never write a
biography of a living subject again I
probably wouldn't buy out write a
biography again certainly not of a
living subject you have you have to go
through the hoops you have to go through
hoops so many different areas a lot of
people want to know where you're coming
from are you going to trash him are you
gonna write a hagiography you know who
are you what are you gonna write and I
just had to you know just under stoat
aliy understandable another landing any
buddy but I had to explain myself to so
many different people and try to
convince people to talk to me Carol
Carol Ellsberg Daniel's ex she she
needed to she needed to talk to their
children first before she'd agreed to
talk to me because her children I guess
she said her children were concerned she
was going to be too critical speak to
welcoming the book Bernard Barker one of
the Watergate burglars when the
Watergate criminals who also was
involved in the break-in of Daniel
Ellsberg's psychiatrists office he
didn't want to talk he said the first
response was he you know didn't have
anything to say about the way I
described my book and then I sent him
another letter didn't get a response
then I called him and he was very busy
during it was absurd the 25th
anniversary the Watergate break-in in 97
I think and so he said call back next
week so I thought I got ahold of him and
then I during the phone interview three
times he tried to stop talking to me
during the phone interview I mean it was
incredible I had to you know bust my
tail to get the gun on this guy then
during the phoner he keeps wanting to
hang up on me this is a quote but it's
got some swearing in it so I'm not gonna
Walter Cronkite
Walter Cronkite Walter Cronkite didn't
respond to my letter and then I wrote
another letter and finally I called and
and I finally got him on the phone and
he tried to end the phone interview and
and the reason I want to talk to Walter
Cronkite is because Walter Cronkite
Daniel Ellsberg was underground after
the Pentagon Papers were published
trying to elude the FBI and Walter
Cronkite arranged a clandestine
interview with him well he was
underground and had to be conducted very
secretively so that the FBI would not
capture Daniel Ellsberg during the
course of making arrangements for the
interview or during the interview and
Walter Cronkite anyway you know shortly
into this phone interview I'm asking
about this whole series of arrangements
they had to make for the interview and
he says well Gordon manning the CB s
vice-president was much more involved in
this than I was you should talk to him
he goes as a matter of fact I don't
think we should spend one more minute
talking about this I think you should
call Gordon Manning
but I got him to keep talking and he was
actually very helpful
mehran kite described the arrangements
for this interview that they had to make
to set up the interview as said it was
quote laborious and highly secret and
almost juvenile in its complexities
there were a lot of mysterious phone
calls back and forth it was all very
cloak-and-dagger and then he talked
about meeting a representative Ellsberg
in in Boston he says I was supposed to
go to the commander hotel in a way to
phone call well it turned out that the
phone booth in the commander hotel was
down by the men's room in the basement
and the foolishness of trying to a
network anchorperson doesn't go anywhere
incognito it was ridiculous I got into
the lobby and I no sooner started
looking around the place
then the manager came out and said mr.
Cronkite what can I do for you he was
urging me to use the phone in his office
he said I didn't have to use the
payphone and I was trying to make
excuses for this and hanging around the
men's room was not conducive to my
reputation they were supposed to call
but I hadn't heard anything I kept going
down and back it wasn't correct it was
just incredibly awkward people were
coming up for my autograph and hopefully
they weren't coming for his autograph
when he was in the men's room and they
and and the manager kept saying I don't
know why you won't wait in my office mr.
Cronkite I'll get you out of this crowd
that kind of thing it was just
ridiculous
and finally Cronkite remembers quote I
was about to give the whole thing up
when when I saw a guy approaching the
door of the lobby of the hotel looked
conspiratorial a young man these were
all young people students I think and
that's why it was so cloak-and-dagger
--is-- but I saw one of them approaching
and he saw me and kind of gave a nod of
recognition and turned to walk back
toward a car waiting at the curb and I
followed him and that's the way we made
contact unquote the young man and the
driver the quote-unquote broken-down
sedan and Cronkite's words apologized to
Cronkite for being late but said they
had to lose a car that had been tailing
them they they then did the quote
secured
surrouding bit unquote and upon reaching
their destination drove around the block
three times so that's what he that's
what he was involved in this this
interview we conducted with Ellsberg on
CBS when Ellsberg was alluding the FBI
Robert Ellsberg was another person it
was Hart who was a you know had to do
some convincing he didn't want to talk
at first and actually I was very lucky
because Daniel Ellsberg his father
happened to be in Japan at that point
when I was trying to interview Robert
when I was back east and so he couldn't
talk to his father directly at that
point but Patricia Ellsberg was home and
I knew Patricia was much more charitable
about the whole thing in Daniel and she
was she's a very nice person and she was
she was actually trying to urge Danny
they won't find a thing to accordin to
cooperate and well she was she saw some
value in a cooperative project so I
suggested that Robert algebra called
Patricia and Patricia gave me a good
recommendation so I Robert talked to me
but I think if his father was not in
Japan he might not have talked to me the
same thing happened with Donald hall
who's a well-known poet writer same
thing have it was then Dan was in Japan
and Patricia was home so I asked Don
hall to call Patricia and put in the way
Don Hall described it Patricia said he's
a good man he wrote he wrote a good book
before the main thing is Dan wants to
write his memoir he doesn't want to give
away stuff and he wants to use his
memoir so Don Hall talk to me but I'm
pretty sure if Dan was in the United
States Don Ho might not have talked to
me and both of those people are very
very helpful
now also in terms of you know source
material for the book I visited a number
of archives
I got one thing I'm very proud of is I
got a lot of Watergate special
prosecution force documents released
through a Freedom of Information Act
request it's the first time I've been
able to use the Freedom of Information
Act successfully I got thousands of
documents released from the National
Archives dealing with Daniel Ellsberg
the Pentagon Papers the break-in his
psychiatrist office the the Nixon
administration's general attempt to
destroy Ellsberg public image etc no
smoking gun on Nixon's Nixon's approval
of the break-in which I was hoping to
find there was no smoking gun there best
thing I found was in a tape recording I
also listened to a whole bunch of Nixon
tapes at the National Archives which
were extremely interesting very very
funny very funny stuff I mean some of
the some of these tapes they really
sound to me like what you might think
common 'el common criminals would sound
like when they're trying to cover
themselves and to get their stories
straight just fascinating stuff they
really sounded like that a lot
no I didn't know about that until
November 1970 that's the first I heard I
heard of it you know and trying to
decide who knew what win and what we're
gonna agree upon and I looked at also
looked at a lot of other Nixon Nixon
documents of the national of the Nixon
projects of the National Archives I
looked at a lot of documents at
Cranbrook prep school Harvard old
Harvard newspapers documents of the JFK
Library the LBJ library papers of
General Edward Lansdale who tells
Ellsberg worked under in Vietnam those
papers are in out Stanford Neil Sheehan
Spey pers he deposit in the Library of
Congress for book II wrote on John Paul
van some people gave me collections of
documents to look at including notes and
letters memos that sort of thing
Ellsberg's ex-wife gave me a number of
documents which were very helpful
including notes on her conversations
with Dan's lawyers her chronology of
events particularly a document she
prepared for her attorney which was very
helpful another person who gave me a
very useful documents was a person named
Norval Jones who was Senator J William
Fulbright stopped a
and he was the person who dealt with the
annual Ellsberg over the Pentagon Papers
he gave me his entire collection of
material of documents on his relations
in dealing with Daniel Ellsberg about
the Pentagon Papers I also looked at
video footage I looked at the Cronkite
interview at the CBS News archive in New
York Ellsberg was great he was at the
peak of his game he was very articulate
very calm he was really on during that
interview now why did I decide to write
about Daniel Ellsberg one of the reasons
is his intersection the intersection of
his life with Vietnam and Watergate I'm
very interested in both Vietnam and
Watergate now the reason he the reason
he got tied up with Watergate is
basically as follows this is kind of a
securest possibly long-winded
explanation but in the late 1960s Daniel
Ellsberg was working at the RAND
Corporation
now the he'd also worked there in the
early sixties now the RAND Corporation
was a think-tank primarily for the Air
Force but for the Pentagon as a whole
and they also did some domestic research
but they were primarily an Air Force
think tank and the RAND Corporation
basically was trying to make air warfare
science they've been set up in 1946 and
Daniel Ellsberg was doing research at
the RAND Corporation in the late 1960s
on the Vietnam War he was doing a big
study on Vietnam he was trying to look
at what went wrong in Vietnam what the
United States could do in the future to
avoid making these sorts of mistakes how
the US could avoid losing these sorts of
wars in the future how we how the US
could have won in Vietnam if we would
have done things differently you know
how to make counterinsurgency more
effective in these sorts of situations
it was basically a counter revolutionary
study is he openly admits he was still
trying to figure out how to win these
sorts of wars debating looking at
exploring how to win these sorts of wars
this at the same time he's copying the
Pentagon Papers I might add which is
somewhat curious
despite his disenchantment with the war
in Vietnam at this time
now he just spent two years in Vietnam
during the period 65 through 67 where
he'd initially been very hawkish very
gung-ho he really wanted to win the war
she wanted the u.s. to do what it would
take to win the war he liked to go out
and combat patrols with US troops to
scout out the enemy he enjoyed
participating in combat he did a lot of
shooting in combat situations he
exhorted US troops on in some situations
their various anecdotes I relate in the
book where he's out with the troops then
he's saying we've got to keep going
we've got to chase Charlie the National
Liberation Front you know now's not the
time to pray take a break let's keep
going you know
these guys don't know how to fight you
know we've got to be more aggressive etc
so I mean it so he was he was very
gung-ho very zealous when he first came
and I came across a memo at the Hoover
at the land in the Lansdale papers of
the Hoover archives which he wrote when
he shortly after he got there and he was
very big on improving US intelligence
against the enemy collecting being
better being better at collecting
intelligence which he thought was a key
to defeating the enemy better
intelligence he went out with what we're
known as census grievance teams which
were invite which were advised by the
CIA and acted as an intelligence
specialist where they they placed
informers and villages to identify
members of the Vietcong for elimination
in in in this memo which he wrote which
was prompted by the possibility of
negotiations and a ceasefire which
Ellsberg opposed of his time he opposed
a ceasefire argument arguing that it
would likely have a wide array of quote
disastrous consequences he urged that
the United States and the government of
South Vietnam expand consolidate and
improved the overall intelligence effort
particularly that of the cia-run Police
Special Branch in South Vietnam
he also said quote as much of the
Vietcong National Liberation Front
political apparatus should be rolled up
by arrests assassination capture
defections
interrogated and where possible used by
the gvn the government of South Vietnam
in Sai warned intelligence functions
before negotiations or ceasefire convert
confer any legitimacy on NLF agents who
can now be treated as criminals so he
really wanted to win and he was very
aggressive about it
pursuing thinking about ways that might
be beneficial to the US but basically he
quickly he quickly became very
discouraged about how the war was being
fought he felt a lot of any also felt a
lot of South Vietnamese military
officials and government leaders were
incompetent ineffective stupid corrupt
he thought a lot of these people needed
to be replaced he was discouraged about
the failure of the US government to get
the right people in there he thought the
United States should basically run South
Vietnam like a colony in many ways you
know I'll be up behind the curtain and
for and for the good of the South
Vietnamese he wanted the United States
exert much stronger influence of
determining what took place in South
Vietnam and the character the leadership
in South Vietnam and he was frustrated
about the failure of people in US
command commissions to command positions
to to take his advice and he was
frustrated about the failure of people
in US command Commission's to take
similar advice of other people like his
friend John Paul van and Vietnam and
Daniel Ellsberg began to doubt that the
United States would ever do what he felt
it needed to do to win the war he also
became more and more troubled by all the
killing and the destruction in Vietnam
particularly since the killings seemed
to be ineffective and he came to feel a
very strong moral resultant moral
revulsion to the killing of innocent
civilians in Vietnam but when he was in
Vietnam he didn't talk about the
morality of the war as far as I could
determine you know his frustration his
sources his firms discouragement were
always about means and results not the
goal and he had a lot of questions about
the war and his frustration was was
great but they were about the me
the United States was using in the
results that we're getting not the
ultimate goal he was a very firm
believer in the cause when he was in
Vietnam now I've got a lot more but does
anybody have any to stop does anybody
have any comments or questions at this
point
mm-hmm oh you know you have a Donald
hall yeah yeah he they met at Harvard
when Niles Berg was a was a I'm gonna
keep going
yeah when there's just a pause when when
Daniels was a freshman at Harvard they
became very good buddies at Harvard and
they're and they're still friends but
there's no enough said right Donald hall
was not political even though he um he
said when he was at Exeter I think is
the prep school that he went to he used
to bring copies of The Daily Worker down
to read for the other students to get
their reaction to him but I don't think
he was I don't think he was it you know
he wasn't I don't think it was that
political I think he did that me only he
called it you he described it to me as
kind of an acting hours I'm sorry
anyway yeah does anyone else have a yeah
what Daniel Ellsberg his sources of
frustration discouragement his views
about what needed to be done I don't
know that that's been talked about a lot
people have talked about Daniel Ellsberg
is a hawk but not to the extent maybe I
wrote it up as I told chapter write it
up sixty-seven he was asked to work on
what became known as the Pentagon Papers
now the Pentagon Papers were a top
secret history of u.s. decision-making
in Vietnam they were commissioned by
Secretary of Defense Robert McNamara in
1967 for this history they the people
who worked on it delved into a great
deal of classified material they were
using classified material from the State
Department Defense Department and the
CIA tons of classified material the
people who worked on this study where
people from think tanks like Rand people
from academia people from the military
people from the State Department people
from the Defense Department and
ultimately the study most study was
completed I believe about 18 months
later was completed in January 1969
again it was a top secret classified
history of u.s. involvement in Vietnam
it was not intended I believe to see the
light of day Robert McNamara said has
said later many times that he intended
it for the use of scholars to determine
what had gone wrong in Vietnam
but I don't know whether that's true or
not it's also not clear when scholars
would actually have access to the thing
as we just sitting there and evolved
somewhere for years and I don't know how
long it would take to actually get this
thing Declassified because there was
7,000 pages when it was completed 47
volumes now Daniel Ellsberg worked on
the Pentagon Papers and he worked on a
the section of the Pentagon Papers
dealing with the kennedy kennedy
decisions of 1961 and but the problem
was he didn't get his work done on it he
either didn't get done what he was
supposed to do
as quickly as he was supposed to get it
done or he didn't write what his boss
the person who head of the study Leslie
Gelb wanted him to write because what
happened was he wrote this he got
heavily into it as far as I could figure
out he got heavily into looking until
the intelligence prior to 1961 and he
looked at a lot of document he's an
extremely curious guy who loves reading
stuff extremely intelligent and I think
what happens he got caught up in reading
these documents and he didn't write what
he was supposed to write so what
happened as Leslie Gelb had to ask
somebody else to take over his section
of the study and write it now Daniel
Ellsberg has said many times that he
wrote the volume of the of the Pentagon
Papers on the kennedy decisions of 61
and that's just simply not true he did a
draft and somebody else said and this is
not what I want to work with and he took
over and wrote it himself
then when the when the Pentagon Papers
were completed in early 1969 Daniel
Ellsberg got access to the cause it's
come full set or he got access to most
of it one of the two he got access to
because he was working at Rand and he
was able to it's a complicated story but
he got he got volumes because of these
things and just in his top three top
secret safe it ran and he wanted to get
the Pentagon Papers out he wanted to
release the papers to the public and one
of the what and I argue in the book that
and I am hypothesizing here on why I
think he wanted to release the Pentagon
Papers and it's based on interviews with
people who knew him very well at the
time it's based on his past behavior and
my understanding of his character and
the things the kinds of things that
motivated him it's also based on his
post Pentagon behaviors behavior what he
acted like after the papers were out but
particularly interviews with people who
knew him well but I argue that in the
book that he wanted to get these papers
out for a very complicated mix of
reasons one is he wanted to end the war
he clearly wanted to end the war and he
thought release of the Pentagon Papers
could end the war in fact he thought
that Pentagon Papers could end the war
fairly quickly if not immediately he
thought they were like dynamite
and I think you probably thought that
other people would see the same things
he saw in the Pentagon Papers so in
other words so one of the reasons was to
I think he went clearly wanted to end
the war and he thought that the getting
the papers out could help discredit the
war greatly but I also think one of the
factors and again I'm hypothesizing here
and I could be wrong but I really don't
I don't think I am wrong on this I think
he wanted greater public recognition I
think he wanted to make a mark I think
he wanted to obtain some fame I think he
wanted the fame and you know you know I
could be wrong but I don't think I am
and also in fairness to him I mean how
many people wouldn't want how many
people don't want greater recognition in
their life but anyway and he's a person
who liked to be prominent he liked to
stand out to star he'd like to be the
center of attention he was a habitual
self-promoter he tended to see himself
in large terms in life he's also a
person who loved praised and loved
applause from people as Charles Nesson
was one of his lawyers during his trial
Charles Nesson being a left-leaning guy
himself may still be as far as I know
probably is he teaches at Harvard Law
School the way Charles Nesson put it to
me was in terms of explaining Ellsberg's
decision to release it this motivation
Nessun said this is a guy who wanted to
make a mark another person I spoke with
who was also a left-leaning person
left-leaning friend of Daniel Ellsberg's
he said what the right wing was saying
he just needed to get his picture in the
paper one way or the other his one of
his girlfriend's Jen Butler knew him
very well
she told me you have to remember that he
was approaching a certain age and he
knew he was brilliant and that nobody
else knew it except the people in his
tight little circle where everything was
top secret but the man on the street did
not know Dan Ellsberg and I think he
wanted him to I think that was partly
what was bothering Dan another person I
spoke with who worked on
Ellsberg's defense team this is also I
progressed you know politically
progressive person this is somebody who
opposed the Vietnam War before Daniel
Ellsberg did again he worked on his
defense team and he supported release of
the Pentagon Papers wholeheartedly he
admired the act he said quote he's an
egomaniac it was a way to be out there
he was a guy who wanted to make it big
and if he could have made it big with
his q clearances had been Secretary of
Defense he would have been perfectly
happy to be up there as long as his name
was on the marquee he seemed like
somebody who's susceptible to whatever
is going to boost his own image his own
presence so I never had any sense in it
so I never had any sense of any sort of
deep values or morality he's basically
an opportunist and this was an
opportunity you know I think the last
part overstated a bit in terms of deep
values of morality I'm just in fact it
definitely does but I get to get the
point here another person of who I spoke
with who was one of the attorneys for
Anthony Russo Anthony Russo was Daniel
Ellsberg co-conspirator on the Pentagon
Papers he was indicted with Daniel
Ellsberg he worked with Daniel Ellsberg
around the Pentagon Papers was a friend
of his one of his attorneys told me
quote had it not been the Pentagon
Papers that would have been something
else and I think that's a very apt
comment and then I think I also
hypothesize in the book that another
reason Daniel Ellsberg another factor
that fed into Daniel Ellsberg's decision
to release the Pentagon Papers was a
desire for him to recover career-wise
his career was not going particularly
well and you got to put it in context of
what he where he's coming from he's a
guy who had been led to think of himself
as special since he was a kid he was a
gifted child clearly brilliant he knew
he was gifted his parents knew he was
gifted pupil his grade school classmates
know he was gifted he was brilliant and
young genius his mother also thought he
was a piano prodigy she thought that he
could be a top-flight top-flight
world-renowned concert pianist something
akin to even of Vladimir Horowitz the
Russian pianist who some people consider
the greatest pianist of all time
he was led to believe he had a special
talent at the piano so in other words he
was led to think of himself mainly
because it was mother but also because
of his incredible intellectual capacity
to be something he led to think of
himself as somebody who was destined for
important accomplishments you know later
in life but I don't think he'd enjoyed
the level of success by this point that
he you know had seemed ticketed for I
don't think he lived up to many people's
expectations of him and his career kind
of come his career had kind of come a
cropper he'd worked in the Pentagon for
a year in the mid 1960s he hadn't cut it
as a pentagon aide he worked for a guy
named John McNaughton who was an
assistant secretary of defense he was a
special assistant to McNaughton but John
McNaughton became disenchanted with
Daniel Ellsberg and probably fairly or
fairly early on Daniel Ellsberg couldn't
be counted on to get work done for John
McNaughton he couldn't get be counted on
to get work done on time
his disorganization was a problem for
John McNaughton was a highly efficient
highly organized guy Ellsberg had a
problem which is with his discretion
which was a problem for McNaughton he
simply C simply hadn't performed
satisfactorily as a pentagon aide and
John McNaughton wanted him out by the
end of that year when he worked for him
he was very disillusioned with him and
probably would have fired Daniel
Ellsberg if Daniel Ellerbee had not gone
to Vietnam and I think that is the
primary one of the primer I should say
one of the primary reasons Daniel
Ellsberg went to Vietnam
he hadn't cut it in Washington he was
damaged goods he wasn't going anywhere
in Washington McNown McNaughton wanted
to get rid of him
McNaughton also helped him go to vietnam
so in other words his career kind of
come a cropper he hadn't been invited
back into the government now in the late
60s he was having a terrible time
getting work done at Rand he couldn't
finish his big Vietnam study he was
working on he was basically treading
water on his Vietnam study and I think
this was a way to bounce back releasing
the Pentagon Papers again I'm
hypothesizing here but I think I'm on
reasonably firm ground and the way
Charles Nesson again his lawyer put it
and this again a guy is totally
sympathetic to releasing the pentagon
paper as a left-leaning guy where's my
page number he said this is Nessen
speaking of Ellsberg he was in some
sense bound for greatness and Dan
Ellsberg had kind of come a cropper and
he was going to recover this was
reflected by the by the delight he took
in being the number one media guy after
the papers were published nessam notes
and the fact that he could call a news
conference that delighted him and I
think that delighted him because it was
consistent with the Ellsberg he wanted
to be and thought he would be then I
also think another theory I put hard in
the book is possibly releasing the
Pentagon Papers was in son sent in some
sense a dart or an arrow at those people
in the establishment who had not
listened to Ellsberg who had not heeded
who had not heeded his advice people who
had turned their back on him I think
also he was motivated partly by
atonement for his own role in the war
for its previous hawkish Ness for
example pointing again here one one
person who worked with them at the time
called him Numa the time said quote he
was terrifically torn about the whole
question of conscience and individual
guilt he was obsessed about his own
personal responsibility Howard Zinn
well-known historian who knew who's a
friend of Daniel Ellsberg's he told me
quote I think it was clear that he was
troubled by the fact that he had been
part of the war machine and that in a
sense he felt that by his act of
releasing the papers he was trying to
make up for that he wanted to do
something to distance to distance
himself from his past and from what he
had done and there's other theories
other arguments I put forward I think
one you know Daniel Ellsberg is someone
who who loved adventure you know he's a
great adventurer he loved drama
he loved excitement he loved danger he
could get a good dose of all of those
things through the Pentagon Papers
adventure releasing the papers and I
also think perhaps you might have been
playing partly to his future wife
Patricia Patricia Ellsberg they were not
married yet she posed the war before he
did
and I think it's quite possible though
maybe wrong again
this is in some sense a way to win her
affections to win her over too short to
show her that he was now against the war
- in fact a friend of his friend of his
put it this way is it up it was okay to
swear on excuse me okay this is what his
friend said I'm very glad he did what he
did but if you're going to try to win
over push try to win over Patricia how
better to do it than with the [ __ ]
Pentagon Papers to prove it that he was
now against the war - naturally he went
overboard which is what he does on
everything he does he goes overboard
this is a friend of Daniel Ellsberg also
a left very a radical speaking and also
Daniel Ellsberg head of another close
friend girlfriend of sorts but perhaps
better just described as a good friend
Johnny key cha knurl who was a Gandhian
peace activist who he became very close
to and it's possible he was also trying
to impress her with it and it's
certainly the kind of thing that we were
impressed her now okay I've got plenty
more but does anybody have any comments
or questions I have a question
concerning your comments about his
inability to get his work done yeah just
what the nature that inability was and
whether it was had to do with conflict
with his bosses because it seems like
I'm not aware of how much the business
of prosecuting war is studying the war
and you know trying to understand how to
do it better and that seems to be what
he was involved in and how there's
legions of individuals devoted to the
study of war you know as it's going on
and whether as he saw that the war
wasn't going in a what he saw a right
way mm-hmm it caused you know emotional
problems or whatever and that's what I
made it my question is essentially well
see I think it goes back to his
childhood and I'm not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about all the way back
in school and at Harvard and at the RAND
Corporation before I went to Vietnam I
mean when I see his mother was extremely
exacting
airing with extremely high standards
very very driving and I think that she
held him up too excessively high
standards and I think that he as a
result he developed he had very high
standards for himself and I think if you
have unrealistically high standards
sometimes and I'm speaking right now
about his writing it makes it difficult
to write because you're always you know
you're trying to accomplish something
that's impossible
he's also you know a disorganized person
which he'd openly admit he has a problem
with self-discipline he's a restless
person he'd rather be moving doing
things he's a man of action basically
and sitting still but I but I think the
problem of standards it is an impatient
person extremely brilliant I mean he's
literally a genius there's no question
about you know but but but I think the
problem with standards is a big been a
big he's had terrible trouble writing
almost like he was memoir was supposed
to come out you know last month and I
was kind of an erase with him on the
memoir but you know consistent with his
past problems he didn't finish it yeah
yeah he's given his reason for I
released them the papers yeah and you've
given a whole bunch of reasons why what
what in your opinion what's the what
what do you think the primary reason was
that he released them well the ones that
I gave was my I think that look at I'm
just theorizing and basing on people
I've talked to him my understanding was
character and such Elena I think know
without a doubt he wanted to end the war
very morally driven person on Vietnam at
that point he's also a guy who loved to
be the center of attention love praise
he loved applause you know he almost had
a childish desire to be prominent before
that it was it fits him like a tee I
mean and I made I actually still was a 1
review of the book where he's he just he
basically he couldn't believe that he
was saying the Daniel Ellsberg acted out
of conscience and he just belittled the
whole idea that he wanted Dan Ellsberg
might have wanted some pain
a man my reaction that was this guy
isn't incredibly an IEE about Daniel
Ellsberg in terms of his character and
what he was like before that look what
he was like after he released the papers
he loved it
I mean he you know and again you know I
can't blame him but on the inter and
he's not like one of the quiet Gandhian
peace activists self-deprecating you
know type that's not Daniel Ellsberg at
all I mean he's a tremendous egotist and
all you got to do is listen to him for
an hour and you know and that's no
question about it I mean it was also the
moral side as well am i right it was a
both right right definitely the question
yeah yeah the you said a co-conspirator
I don't even know no didn't even know
his name no I mean that span spoke to me
a lot about Daniel Ellsberg and why
don't we know his co-conspirator well
that's a good point
and his co-conspirators Anthony Russo
Anthony Russo was a good friend of his
at the RAND Corporation they work
together on copying the Pentagon Papers
Anthony Russo feels like he played a
significant role in getting Daniel
Ellsberg to release the Pentagon Papers
because he according to him he urged
Daniel Ellsberg to get these things out
a number of times and he also feels like
he played some role in turning Ellsberg
against the war I don't know about that
or not but nonetheless when the papers
came out Anthony Russo he wasn't a died
at first first it was just Daniel
Ellsberg and died and six months later
Russo was also indicted
when the first papers first came out
Anthony Russo refused to testify before
the grand jury about Daniel's even
though he was offered full immunity and
he says he basically didn't want to
think on a friend even though he was
offered full immunity wouldn't testify
it but then after Russo was indicted
probably primarily because he refused to
testify before the grand jury
at least that was my main reason after
he was indicted Daniel Ellsberg really
didn't want to have that much to do with
him and during the trial he basically
didn't want to spend time with him he
didn't want to talk to him that much you
know he kind of wanted to be on stage
by himself and he also felt being paired
with Anthony Russo would hurt his
defense I think because Anthony Russo
was openly countercultural and openly
radical and he didn't like being paired
with I think he thought it would hurt
his defense and I think he thought it
might hurt his image and I think he
thought it might hurt his respectability
with the establishment his pairing with
Russo but my must accounts Daniel
Ellsberg did not treat Anthony Russo
very well he basically walled him off
treated him condescendingly you know
exhibit a sense of superiority superior
superiority over him even though Russo
had refused to testify about Daniel
Ellsberg before the grand jury and they
thought they were in it together so
Anthony Russo feels betrayed by Daniel
Ellsberg and frankly doesn't seem to
like you very much anymore so
that back to Ellsberg's sort of moral
change between being a hog and and and
being openly against the war did almost
from the way you describe his
personality would I could imagine him
claiming like a moral epiphany or
something like that
did he ever say anything like that yeah
you know that's a very that's a very
good question because he did claim a
moral epiphany and he attended well
first this woman Jonica Charl I think
clearly did have a big influence on the
Gandhian peace activist a woman he
became close to and also there was a
person named Randy Keeler who was an
anti draft activist and he became friend
of Daniel L became a friend of Daniel
Ellsberg's and there was a big anti-war
Conference in the fall of 1969 sponsored
by the war resisters International and
went Randy Keeler spoke at this
conference and he was headed for prison
soon for resisting the draft and he gave
a very emotional speech about his
situation other people who were
resisting the draft and Friends of his
and were now in jail for resisting the
draft and a lot of and it was a very
emotional speech and Randy Couture
started crying during a speech and some
members the audience started crying and
the speech affected Daniel Ellsberg is a
very emotional person and the speech
affected him greatly and the thought of
you know the way he described as a
thought of if this isn't the best a
talented smart young American can do to
oppose the wars to go to jail you know
what's this country coming to what can I
do to stop the war you know finally you
go to jail and he went to the bathroom
during killer speech and he broke down
in the bathroom and cried for a long
time so he describes this as a pivotal
turning point but he also tends to
credit many other people politically for
his turn around almost like I get the
sense sometimes it's because he's trying
to convince people that he was acting
solely out of political motivations are
not other motivate that other
motivations didn't enter into it so I
don't have any question that Randy
theater had a big impact
Iran or Johnny key general or other
political activists but I think he tends
to overplay that because he wants to
portray himself as act
solely out of moral and political
reasons I don't think that's the case
did you yeah what was his life like
after the Pentagon Papers what did he do
well there's only one chapter that's the
last chapter um
okay his trial was over in 73 he became
a political activist he's done a lot of
anti-nuclear political activism
including here in Colorado around Rocky
Flats at one point activism around
Central America he has you know it's
funny he made some interesting comments
at that point he you know after the
trial was over he said I'm not an
activist you know I'm a researcher and
writer you know he's an intellectual is
what he is but he's at one point he said
but I felt like I had to do it because
people were calling in their marks as
the markers or marks or their shits and
I felt like I had to people have
contributed to the Ellsberg defense fund
and I felt like I had to do something in
return
but activism he's also tried to write
and successfully largely he's written a
number of articles but he's never been
able to write the book he wanted to
write he wanted to write a book secret
history of new US nuclear policy yeah
you know basically just a book on US
nuclear policy because he did a lot of
work on nuclear command and control in
the early sixties working for the
Pentagon as a consultant in at the RAND
Corporation he didn't get that book done
he wanted his writer he wanted to write
a memoir for probably since 1971 maybe
even before then I don't know and he's
never been able to do that now maybe
he'll finish the man why he might I know
actually his son Robert was working with
him on his memoir Robert being an editor
actually a book editor so Robert was
helping him when I'm in LA and but you
know I'm not exactly sure what it does
with a lot of his time
I don't know what he you know I think
it's a legitimate question to ask but
he's done but but the too many things
he's done a lot of political activism
and and tried to write and he's right
now he's trying to finish
okay do you dislike him you know there's
some parts of him I like a lot and
there's some parts of my dislike the
things I like about him is you know his
mind is intelligence and he's a very
stimulating person to talk to I like the
sense of humor I mean he has a really
good sense of humor a few sometimes he
likes to make points with a sense of
humor like you know it's like he's
saying something he's not it's not sorry
it's not like gregarious jovial it's
more like trying to make a point maybe
make a point against somebody or
something but he does have a good sense
of humor they actually did a.m. he does
good imitations I mean he did like a
very funny Henry Kissinger imitation one
time to me you know and he and I admire
he's like you know he's a risk-taker and
I admire his you know his looseness and
and I admire what he did I mean I
wouldn't have chosen the right amount if
I didn't totally support what he did and
and as my own of the fact that he did it
because there was a courageous act and
he's risking prison even though you know
he's now already said I expected to go
to the prison for the rest of my life
for releasing his papers and I think
that's simply not true I think he just
he's not being fully honest about that
because he tried to desperately to get
these papers out in a way which were a
way in which he could avoid going to
prison that was getting him out to a
member of Congress he desperately wanted
to get these papers out through senator
J William Fulbright or
Paul McCloskey or George McGovern
because you know legislators they have
immunity legislative immunity they also
have the security clearances legally
required to receive classified
information and when you couldn't get
you couldn't get these papers out to
remember of Congress they didn't they
wouldn't they wouldn't do it they
wouldn't play ball with him basically
and he became very frantic increasingly
nervous about that so when he now says
what you said repeatedly I expect to go
to the prison for the rest of my life
for releasing these things I think is
just being dishonest about that I think
he wants to portray himself as I was
always on a suicidal mission totally
political totally morally based I was
willing to sacrifice myself but I just
don't think that's true and I don't
blame him for not wanting go to prison I
mean who wants to go to prison
don't blame it all for trying to go to
get some sort of legal cover amazing but
then they get back to your question the
things that I didn't like about him but
probably the some of the things that a
lot of people don't like about him
his ego which is gargantuan his his
tendency there to you know
chronically exaggerate his involvement
in events as sometimes it's fabrications
about what he did his self-righteousness
at times he has a sense you know he's
not you know he's not as funny he's not
some people are just come off as
arrogant because I think I mean this is
my own take on because their vocal
inflections and how they talk you know
and I heard myself and it's usually when
I'm feeling insecure is when I start
sounding like that she doesn't
ultimately sound like that usually but
there's this real sense of superiority
about it and I think it goes back to he
was a kid and I think the fact that fact
once he released the Pentagon Papers it
said that that feeling of superiority
greatly and I think he thinks in some
ways he's kind of a special guy that
part of him I didn't like so there was a
mix I mean there's some things I really
liked about him some things and I guess
you know when it since i sat unless it's
on for a long time and eagerly listened
to him and after hearing so many things
that I thought simply we're not true or
he was trying to boost his own profile
things I guess that kind of started
irritating me like I said that's why it
became kind of contentious with him at
times but he didn't think he said we
didn't he said he didn't think I
understood him well and I'm sure he
still thinks I don't understand him well
and he said we didn't seem to resonate
well when I talked to him I mean that
may well be true but it was a mixed bag
and I certainly didn't start out it's
the idea that I'm gonna write a very
critical biography note that was not
part of my plan at all it was I wanted
right in vitamins I you know I supported
release of the Pentagon Papers I admired
the fact that he did it really
interested in Vietnam glaciers in
Watergate he's a very complex intriguing
fascinating guy incredibly interesting
childhood with his mother his mother
died at eight when he was aged fifth
when he was aged 15 when his parents
they were driving from he live in
Highland Park Michigan and they were
driving to Denver actually for a party
for that his mother's one of his
mother's brother was throwing and what
happened was he and his sister and his
you know it was it was his two parents
and his sister driving and they the
night before they got into Iowa they
they their reservations were there
wherever they were going to stay the
person that had been cancelled according
to the way the stories the way
Danielle's were tell the story is
apparently they had left on time so when
they got the weather in a stay the
reservations were canceled they had to
sleep outdoors on the dunes in Lake
Michigan that night his father couldn't
sleep I was to call Daniel sleeped a
little bit
his mother and sister slept in the car
they get going the next morning it was
I've got it and there's a section on
this inherent high temperature and
Davenport that day was in the 80s it's a
hot day his dad is talking about who
he's got to stop and sleep you can't go
on he's getting tired
his mother is saying no we've got to get
to the party he's saying well then
you've got to drive and she said no I
can't drive you got to be fresh for the
party cedra so they stopped for lunch
and daven some Ivy Lee was outside with
in Iowa they have lunch to get back in
the car shortly after lunch his dad
apparently falls asleep at the wheel as
far as I know that's the accurate
account of why what happened maybe
something else happened but the way
Daniel tells it his father fell asleep
at the wheel and it certainly makes
sense fell asleep at the wheel the car
goes off the road smashes into a culvert
his mother dies according to Daniel his
brother his half-brother later told him
that his mother had been decapitated in
the crash because the cuz it tore the
whole right side of the car off his
sister died I believe was about two
years younger than him Daniel suffered a
broken there's my son there for Daniel's
Daniel suffered a broken knee and he
went he had a big gash on his face big
flap of skin according to newspaper our
I looked at a bunch of newspaper
articles of the time on this apparently
some broken ribs - he goes into a coma
he wakes from the coma according to him
about 36 hours later and his only
thought when he wakes from the coma is
now I don't have to play the piano
anymore so that's a that's an incredible
I mean that's a very telling reaction
when your mother dies now I don't have
to play the piano anymore so it suggests
how great his trauma was or his feelings
of resentment or oppression that he had
towards his mother who made him practice
the piano for long hours who again
thought he was a piano prodigy you know
his life revolved around his mother and
when he was when he was a child he
didn't he was a loner in the
neighborhood he didn't hang out with the
other kids much when he went to
Cranbrook prep school he tended to be
withdrawn and remote and then his mother
dies and they didn't have played the
piano anymore and so I mean there's a
lot of stuff like that with that I found
interesting about Daniel Ellsberg's yeah
that made me look at him as a very
fascinating intriguing complicated guy
you know in terms of his brilliance I
mean the guy you know she graduates
first his class at Cranbrook he scores
highest in the state of Michigan on a
scholastic aptitude test to get into
Harvard he goes to Harvard he graduates
third in his class of over a thousand
people his I talked to two of his
professors there who called him one of
the brightest students they ever had at
Harvard
then he gets he gets elected he goes off
in the Marines which was very unusual it
looks like he's going to go into the
Society of fellows at Harvard but he
decides to join the Marines I mean how
many people of that intellectual caliber
will just go join the Marines you know
very odd thing to do it but he loves
adventure you know I probably wanted to
prove its manhood he was you know what's
change of the piano as a as a boy he
loved to experience new things it's a
very curious guy extremely curious I
mean he'll talk to you and I was like
you haven't read that book I mean and it
just you know he's just everything
interesting and then he and then he does
one of the Society of fellows at Harvard
the
fellows at Harvard is probably you could
argue it's even superior to receiving a
Rhodes Scholarship it's like they give
you it was a program that was created at
Harvard earlier by the president of
Harvard I think it's a Lawrence Lowell
and basically the idea was the super
brains they need a program that they
need a looser program in the standard
ph.d program these people they need more
freedom to develop ideas then you're
allowed within the standard PhD program
with all the requirements so that if
you're selected to be a junior fellow at
Harvard you have three years of free
time you didn't have to go to classes
you didn't take exams you didn't do any
teaching you could do what you wanted to
do and the idea was these people are so
smart they need complete freedom to
pursue their intellectual interest and
he was a junior fellow Donald Hall was
also a junior film actually then he goes
off to the RAND Corporation and he's
considered one of the brightest people
around if not the brightest person in
the RAND Corporation the RAND
Corporation is composed of intellectual
types physicists mathematicians
political sciences etc some people
thought he was the brightest person at
rate he was considered a super genius
you know possible future Nobel Prize
winner when he went to read so he's dead
you know legitimately an extraordinarily
intelligent guy with tremendous capacity
and but I think one of the tragedies of
his life and he's had terrible trouble
realizing that intellectual potential
and it's a very of course it's a very
sensitive subject with him you talked to
him about it he doesn't I don't he
hasn't agree with that assessment is
anyone else home uh-huh
could you just kind of sum up what you
think I mean you say chronically
exaggerate his role and yet you found a
very fascinating important character and
the whole Vietnam and put it in context
what do you think his role was was the
what was this important significance to
the whole I think his main significance
is when he released the Pentagon Papers
it caused the Knicks administration to
overreact and they set up what became
known as the plumbers unit and the
plumbers undertook a series of abuses of
governmental power or engaged in a
series of abuses
governmental power one of the things
they did basically the Nixon
administration overreacted dramatically
to this this publication's of Pentagon
Papers and one of the things the
plumbers did was to break into Daniel
Ellsberg's psychiatrists office Louis
fielding in Beverly Hills and I think
they did it basically for three main
reasons they were looking for any kind
of information they could find on Daniel
Ellsberg by the way his ex-wife was the
person who told the FBI that he'd
actually seen a psychoanalyst and then
when the FBI learned this he immediately
wanted to know who is this psychoanalyst
because she told the FBI that he assured
her that he had told this former
psychoanalyst all about what he'd done
in terms of copying the papers so the
FBI here is this they go well we gotta
find out who this guy is
so they request they put in a request
and it might have been up at the level
of jr. Hoover actually was saying ask
for who this person is she called or she
spoke with another former psychiatrist
who treated both current Daniel Ellsberg
the 1960 early 1960s before he went to
fielding and this psychiatrist gave her
Lewis Fielding's name she then phoned it
in to the FBI and they broke into Lewis
Fielding's office because they thought I
think for three main reasons they wanted
any kind of information that you get on
Daniel Ellsberg they want an information
of who he was exactly what were his
motives what were his intentions what
were his capabilities what else might he
have planned
he was gonna release something else is
this going to continue no we're going to
see more top-secret documents appearing
in the papers I think another reason
they broke into it as they wanted to
they thought that any information they
got out of a psychiatrist's office they
could give to the CIA because the CIA
was doing a psychiatric profile of
Ellsberg and they'd already done you
know to basically to illuminate his
motivations and his character and the
CIA had already done one psychiatric
profile of Ellsberg and the plumbers did
not think was an adequate profile that
was too superficial too short etc so I
think when the plumbers went in there
they thought well you know they want a
better profile okay we'll get them some
more stuff and you can do a better
profile
you know we'll give you some more stuff
in Danielle's brand of his psychiatrist
office and then I think another obvious
reason for going in there with the
collect dirt to collect dirt damaging
information on Ellsberg with it which
they could leak to the press to destroy
his public image and I think they
expected to find you know evidence of
psychological imbalance evidence of
maybe drug use and strange sexual
practices so so when Ellsberg releases
the papers they set up the plumbers the
plumbers engage in a whole series of
abuses of power including the break-in
including they attempted to assault
Ellsberg physically at an anti-war
demonstration later they also [ __ ] to
you know they leaked they tried to
destroy Ellsberg's publicly image you
know this at a time when he's either in
pretrial or on trial so you're talking
obstruction of justice and there were
other acts so but but the plumbers
abuses of power became a significant
part of the Watergate scandal okay so
when Ellsberg released the papers the
plumbers hence Watergate and once you
have Watergate you know you're talking
about bringing down president you know
President Nixon and you're also probably
talking about a significant impact on
the Vietnam War because Watergate
undercut Nixon's credibility in Congress
and really inhibited what he wanted to
get done in Congress you simply didn't
have the credibility he had before and
members of Congress were mad at him
because he wasn't releasing tapes that
they wanted so I